[Musica]
vi è mai capitato di innamorarvi di un
luogo non in un luogo quello del primo
appuntamento è quello del primo bacio ma
di un luogo di un posto specifico quello
dove avete lasciato il cuore quello dove
avete depositato un ricordo perché i
ricordi si depositano come la polvere e
gli edifici sono i custodi della polvere
a me è successo con la biblioteca
malatestiana
per chi non la conoscesse la biblioteca
malatestiana e stata inaugurata il 15
agosto 1450 cose da malatesta novello
signora il cesena su progetto
dell'architetto matteo nuti e della più
antica biblioteca umanistica al mondo
tuttora vivente perché ancora oggi
vengono dati in prestito libri e
manoscritti
tutto ha inizio durante una
chiacchierata con il professor fratelli
docenti di restauro del dipartimento di
architettura dell'unita di bologna
una mattina a quel tempo avevamo delle
sonde che usavamo in ambito didattico
per misurare la temperatura dell'aria la
velocità e umidità dell'aria
concentrazione di anidride carbonica e
altri parametri
ci siamo chiesti dove che possiamo
applicare queste sonde beh visto che
siamo a cesena che c'è la biblioteca
malatestiana patrimonio unesco
sono 500 anni che ci sono gli stessi
muri lo stesso arredo gli stessi
manoscritti di fatto è come se ci fosse
la stessa area
vediamo il giorno stesso siamo andati
dalla direttrice biblioteca paolo errani
con le sonde e abbiamo spiegato più o
meno quello che intendevamo a fare anche
se non era del tutto chiaro neanche a
noi ma siamo stati convincenti perché il
giorno stesso abbiamo installato le
sonde più o meno il senso che non
esserci nemmeno le prese elettriche
l'intera biblioteca abbia dovuto trovare
una prolunga molto lunga con un po di
prove però siamo riusciti a partire come
però con il monitor monitoraggio
inoltre abbiamo chiesto ai custodi di
compilare un registro nel quale dove non
riportare gli accessi il muro di
visitatori e gli orari di apertura delle
finestre per controllare l'affollamento
e la velocità dell'aria
ogni settimana andavo con il mio
portatile a scaricare manualmente i dati
e ogni volta incontrava un custode
diverso all'epoca ce n'erano
sei o sette e mi chiedevano allora
allora come la ricerca come vanno i dati
come vanno le misurazioni e poi volevano
sapere la mia opinione sull'operato del
loro collega il giorno precedente perché
sa ieri c'era la nebbia e hanno tenuto
aperte le finanziamenti secondo me
oppure ieri c'era il sole manutenuto più
sulle finanziamenti secondo me ognuno
aveva la propria opinione sul corretto
modo di gestire il microclima della
biblioteca sono stati una fonte
d'informazione utilissimo la ricerca è
durata quasi un anno dopo tre mesi aveva
incominciato a guardare i dati a
guardare i primi risultati e abbiamo
visto che c'era qualcosa di strano
perché i parametri l'andamento dei
valori era fatto troppo bene era quasi
come se ci fosse un impianto di
climatizzazione e ci siamo chiesti come
è possibile che vada così bene abbiamo
deciso di fare un rilievo insito quando
un architetto non sa che cosa fare un
giro in cantiere allora la biblioteca
malatestiana è costituita da un primo
piano dove si trova la biblioteca un
ampio sottotetto reato nella parte
superiore che consente di mitigare la
radiazione solare e poi un ampio volume
sottostante dove si trova il museo
archeologico
questa configurazione consente di
evitare i picchi di temperatura durante
l'estate che comporterebbero un aria
secca che rischia di tirare di crepare
in legno o i manoscritti e i picchi
inferiori di temperature che potrebbero
comportare la formazione di condensa
umidità e muffe funghi più tardi d'armi
tutti i danni che potrebbero colpire i
manoscritti o l'arredo dette così
sembrava una botta di fortuna a matteo
nuti il progettista è andata bene ha
avuto una buona idea in realtà non è
proprio così perché continuando la
nostra ricerca
ma questa volta negli archivi abbiamo
notato che tutte le biblioteche
umanistiche dell'epoca avevano la stessa
hanno la stessa sezione architettonica
biblioteca di salamanca di san marco
allowed tutte hanno la stessa
configurazione non era quindi un caso ma
era una prassi quella era la soluzione
tecnica dell'epoca per la corretta
conservazione dei manoscritti e qui non
abbiamo avuto il salt epistemico come si
chiama cambio di paradigma non è più
l'architettura che determina il meteo
clima ma è il microclima che determina
la forma architettonica
detto così sembra quasi ovvio nel senso
che è ovvio che l'architettura serva per
il cancro delle persone manufatti
eccetera ma quando si studio quando si
progetta di architettura il fatto che
all'interno di quei muri ci sia
dell'area e che quell'area debba avere i
parametri per garantire il campo delle
persone non è così ovvio
un indizio non fa una prova da questa
intuizione siamo andati avanti con una
serie di ricerca diversi casi studio
ogni racconto due il primo è villa
medici la petraia voluta da costruita
dal 1600 dai medici vicino a firenze ed
è costituita da una grande villa con una
corte centrale la villa fu acquisita nel
1800 dai savoia quando firenze era
capitale e per dare una festa durante
l'inverno e savoia deciso di ricoprire
la corte centrale con una struttura in
acciaio e vetro creando di fatto una
sorta di serra e alterando il mio primo
originario
noi abbiamo misurato e modellato la
villa e abbiamo visto cosa succede con e
senza la copertura della corte e noi
l'abbiamo tolto la corte e portato
indietro nel tempo la villa utilizzando
i dati climatici originali del 1600 con
le delle stazioni metereologiche volute
dai medici tra le prime stazioni
metereologiche al mondo il secondo caso
studio a palazzo guiccioli a ravenna in
questo caso abbiamo modellato la stanza
dove tra il 1819 e 1821 dimorò lord
byron il poeta perché era in maniera
morato di teresa which c'è una storia
d'amore dietro comunque noi abbiamo
misurato i modellato la stanza e saremmo
in grado di definire se i vestiti che
indossa lord byron i vari ritratti di
quel periodo sono adatti a quella stanza
o meglio se l'ormai ne sentiva a caldo o
freddo
grazie a questa serie ricerca abbiamo
qualificato un nuovo ambito disciplinare
che abbiamo chiamato king h item
historic indoor macro climate o micro
clima storico il quale mette al centro
il microclima come strumento di
conoscenza del patrimonio storico e
della sua conservazione
l'obiettivo di questo ambito
disciplinare non è solo misurare e
monitorare modellare i parametri
climatici per la corretta conservazione
eccetera eccetera sugli argomenti questi
momenti c'è ampia letteratura
l'obiettivo è imparare dal microclima
imparare dall ara impari imparare come e
perché l'architettura è stata costruita
come si vestivano all'epoca qual'era
l'alimentazione perché l'alimentazione
collegati al metabolismo e quindi la
sensazione di comfort quale roy le
abitudini gli usi costumi eccetera
eccetera
molto si può imparare dall area questo
perché l'architettura dice molto di più
di chi l'ha costruita dei progettisti
dei proprietari dice degli artigiani che
l'hanno costruita delle tecniche
costruttive e molto si può come dicevo
imparare all'area perché grazie all'area
non possiamo spostare la nostra
modellazione costiere possiamo spostare
gli edifici nel passato e nel presente e
nel futuro
pensate agli effetti del cambiamento
climatico sul patrimonio culturale
quando entrate in un edificio non per
forza un edificio storico
fateci caso fateci caso ha come il
vostro corpo reagisce
fateci caso a come vi sentite a come
state se state bene o male può in
entrata in un'architettura non
guardatela solo con gli occhi
guardatela con i piedi vorrei che la con
la pelle guardatela col naso mi sono
innamorato della biblioteca malatestiana
dicevo e penso che per la conservazione
del patrimonio culturale per dei centri
storici dell'architettura della comunità
per la tutela del territorio del
paesaggio
prima ancora della costituzione prima
ancora dell unesco prima ancora delle
leggi e prima ancora delle ricerche
della tecnica prima di tutto bisogna
innamorarsene dell'architettura perché
quando la conosce così bene da sentirne
l'area a sentirne il respiro farà di
tutto perché venga tutelata grazie